bu
amaca tıkladıktan sonra beni çağırdı
sebeplerine bir tanıtım önce
kütüphanesiyle olup sonra nasıl bir yola
geldiğimde ilgili olabilir Biraz ben de
işte Muğla fen lisesindeyim
Pardon
ben de Muğla Fen Lisesi'ni deydim
sonra Ama tabi benim hayatımda
mühendislik ve yaptık gibi bir şeydi o
zamanlar hayalim ve sonra ise kendimi
burada buldum ve iki dediğim yollardan
bir tanesi burada Aslında bunu
anlatacağım Yani yolculuğumuzun bizi
geçirdiği Her zaman kötü olmuyor veya
kötü diye düşündüm şeylerin Aslında
nasıl iyi bir yere geçirdi ile ilgili
Ben Muğla sendeyken işte ikinci senemde
dışlandım için Aslında bugün yazar oldum
bu da şöyleydi lise 1 değildim Kız
arkadaşı demişim ilk defa kız arkadaşım
vardı her şey onunla yapıyoruz heryere
onunla gidiyoruz başka arkadaş edilmemiş
email ise ikiye geldiğimde artık böyle
herkes arkadaşlıkları oluşturmuş ve
birlikte yaşanmışları vardı ben tek
başımaydım ve tekrar böyle bir arkadaş
edinmeye girmeyeyim dedim giremedim de
zaten o ara full kitap okumaya başladım
zamandır kötü çizmeye başladım Çünkü bir
şekilde tekrar var olmam gerekiyor
ilgili Çekmem gerekiyor tekrar böyle
aralarına girmem gerekiyor karikatürü
odadan çıkıp Yatılı okulda bir odanın
karikatür dergileri en etkili olduğu
dönemde
sürekli bir şeyler çiziyorum ediyorsun
falan şans öyle konuştum Öyle
kitaplarını okuyorum O da Galatasaray
Lisesi'nde okumuş yatılı okul 5 dolar
yalnız dönem geçirmiş sandım ki Evet
işte ben de o gibiyim aynı Ben falan de
bir onu öpüyorum Sonra her şeyin okumaya
başladım çattı oyunları okumaya başladım
derken ben ya zaten arada yazanlar da
var sabirsiz olacak okuduktan sonra
acaba bende yapabilirmiyim yolu olur ya
da ben onlar kadar yazamam birkaç tane
olur belki biraz daha Acaba ben
yapabilir miyim yoluydu ve bir şeyler
yazmaya başladım Sonra bir s3'e
geldiğimde artık böyle biliyordum ne
yapmak istediğimi 10 E tabi mühendisi
olmam gerekiyor çünkü öyle de
öğrenmiştim ve aile bunu anlatım
anlatamıyorum Ya bu üstten anne yüz
başladı Aslında biraz da bu yüzden bu
ailemin işte Köyden gelen bir ailenin
biraz daha Eski kafa olsun oluşundan bir
ailenin NASA'nın beni şu an desteklemeye
başladı ile ilgili bir yolculuk biraz
Neyse o zaman işte bir ailevi durumları
falan da var derken bir şekilde bunları
ikna ettim çünkü babama aileme daha çok
güvende insanları anlatmıştım derdimi
istemeye istemeye mi tamam dediler söze
girdi söz alsın olmadı bir o zaman Mimar
Sinan oldu Mimar Sinan geldim ama artık
böyle ne yapacağımı bilmiyorum ne
diyeceğimi de bilmiyorum ve dergileri
yazı gönderiyoruz Öykü gönderiyorum ama
artık bizde şey Yeni bir tarz
oluşturmaya çalışıyoruz ve bu
reddediyoruz o zaman dedik ki biz de
kendi derdimize çıkaralım Berkay Ne
mutlu o zaman daha 20 yaşındayım o zaman
büyük ücretli işte mekanları falan gidip
sponsorlarımız bu dönemde bulamadığımız
dönemde de Ailelerimiz destek almayacak
zaten aileniz iş yapmamız isteme
İçinizde sayısal kökenli biraz daha
köstek olmaya çalışıyorum O zaman ve
artık adında bir daha geç kaldık ama
biraz da şeydim destek alalı çıkarmıştı
mail atarak oluyor uğraşacak bunu
uğraşacak bu üç yılın sonunda artık
benim kafamda şöyle bir iş vardı
sap yazmak istiyordum fakat yine aynı
şekilde ve farklı kitap olduğu için ne
yapacağımı bilmiyordum burada süreçte de
şöyle bir şey oldu Twitter açtım odandan
yazdım ki de parça parça Twitter atmaya
başladım bu şu yüzden önemli biliyorum
yani şu yayınevlerine uğraşıyorsun
dövüşüyorsun hiçbir şekilde ulaşamadım
şey sadece sosyal medyada artık karşılık
bulduğu için seni de hali görebiliyorlar
bu onu o zaman keşfetmem yetişkin anda
benim için Ama birileri önemli
söyleyeyim işte bu işte bir buçuk
dakikası diyorum Çünkü o zaman onu dizi
olarak düşünüyorduk işte farklı beş
sayfasını Twitter futbola bu ne oldum 3.
ayın sonunda patladı hesabı açtım az az
takipçim arkadaşlarım vardı derken işte
bir gün aptal bir yerde iftarda edip biz
onun Hiç bilmediğim deseydi bitir Bir
anda böyle etkileşim almaya başladı
yayılmaya başladı işte ona böyle müşteri
sana öyle yerlere çekmeye başlayacağım
artık yayınevlerinin ilgisini çekmeye
başlamıştım Yani ilk defa beni şansın
dönüştü Çünkü reddedildiğini işte
aileden destek görmedim ve yazdığım
şeylerin karşılık bulmadı yerde sosyal
medya bir çevre böyle karşılık bulmuştu
orada yani belki denk gelmiş size bak
denk gelmişsiniz sonra ev arkadaşı
hikayesiydi ve ben orada gerçek bir
hikaye yemiş gibi anlattım orada
gerçekten ev arkadaşım varmış ve
arkadaşım böyle birşey yaşıyormuş gibi
Çünkü bir yandan da Tap olarak basılması
istiyorum ama aynı zamanda Hadi de olsa
olur diyorum Çünkü kafamı karışık olduğu
zamanlarda kafam zaten kaşık olması
gereken zamanda
bu sonra bu istiyorum önce bir tane de
az sonra
A hadi bunun dizisini yapmamızı Ozan Bey
tane ile görüşmüştüm ve tamamiyle
çalışmaya başladı Altay uğraştık falan
filan olmadı bu sonra ben de ne
yapacağımı bilmiyorum meslek sahibi
olmak istiyor ve bu şekilde karnında
doymuyor ne yapacağımı bilmiyorum şöyle
bir şey olmuştu sanırım o zaman kodiden
reklamı yapacak ajansa Ben mail atmıştım
ama yine de böyle sevdiğim olmadığı için
sevimli Aslında biraz daha eğlenceli
İşte bu en sevdiğim en sevdiğim renk
sarı Aslında oradan itibaren geliyor
kendimi anlattım bir çivi biraz
eğlenceli olsun biraz cümle kurabildiği
görmelerini istiyorum yaz da Ne o an çok
farklı cümle kurduğunu falan sanıyordum
yapılarıyla oynuyorum yapıbozumculuk
üzerine konuşuyordum Orada seven sonunda
en sevdiğim renk sarı demiştim oradan
güldükleri içinde 2014 yılında beni
görüşmeye davet etmişlerdi hiç böyle bir
gibi görmedik bu ne diye düşünerek
orada ol bu işte o bir cümle benim
şehrim reklam ajansına girmemiş Sana
sağlam işte ve yani benim için o hayal
bile etmedim ya Çünkü öyle
yetiştirilmesi işte LGS ye kaldığımız
zaman dile getirdi şu anda bilmiyorum
LGS kazanacaktır sonra iyi bir
mühendislik benim hayalim de anneler
tabi çok istiyordu oradan işte bir
cümleyle buraya kadar gelmişti o yüzden
mesajını sevdiğim renk sırası çok
güzelmiş yemek istediğin Artık yeni
Global yeni Global olduğunu düşünüyorum
atmak isteyen şeylerin Aslında insanın
daha çok ilgisini çekti bu zaten şu an
televizyonlarda Bizler de görebilirsiniz
daha küçük daha taban hikayeleri işlem
140journos böyle başlamıştı daha Tamam
hikayelerine giden veya aynı şekilde cep
hikayeleri var buradan da Reklamcılık
serüvenim başladı ama Reklamcılık yapar
kendi her zaman bir hikaye peşinde
koşuyorum bazen bir anlattığımız
şeylerde hikayesi olması gerekiyordu bu
ve daha önce yapılmamış yine yapmaya
çalışıyor en başından beri hevesli muydu
işte ya gözümüzün önündeymiş bu fikri
dedirtecek abi benim de aklıma
gelebiliriz dedirtecek şekilleri ilk
yapan olma gibi bir gözüm vardı Böyle
şeyler bulmaya çalışmıştır çevreme o
gözle bakıyorum burada reklamcılıkla
ilgili yaptığım babaannem hikayesini
anlatmıştım onu anlatacağım Bir organ
bağışı için
babaannemin Aslında acı bir yaşam öyküsü
varsa çok acıklı olmasının sebebi
dedemle ilgili neden mutsuz bir evliliği
var Neden sonra dost hayatı yaşadığı
biri var derken
kötü bir aile ortamında büyük büyüdüm
yani orada babaannemi aslında ama
öldükten sonra yazmıştım bu hikaye
babaannem işte köydeki hayatını alınca
büyük büyümesi küçülmesi şey büyümesi
çocukların yetiştirilmesi dedemle
ilişkileri Benim bile Babaanneme bakış
açım sabah sevmiyorum çocukken Çünkü ve
asla cimri olduğunu düşünüyordum ama
aslında Şimdi düşündüm de hayatımdaki
her şeyi Elif o zaman bir kadının başka
şeyleri sahip olma çabası mıymış Aslında
bizim dedi ve sürekli temizlik yapıyorum
temizlik hastasıydı çok sessizdi işte
belki de kafasını meşgul etmeye
çalışıyordu o an şu an Bunu
anlayabiliyorum bu hikaye üzerine
gitmeye çalıştım ve şöyle birşey oldu
oldu bir kere anlattım ben sormadık
okuma yazması olmayan bir kızın bile ben
vardım diyebilmek için hayatı boyunca
yok sayılmış bir kadının ben vardım
diyebilmek için organlarını bağışladılar
bir reklam yapmıştık iki anlatmış
reklamda O çok karşılık buldu Çünkü
oradan bağışla dini önlemler geleneksel
ondan nasıl onaylanmıyor sağa Ama
insanların Evet geleceği bir parça
bırakmak veya ben vardım ya Kimse benim
için bir şey yapmıyor kendini ben
Bilirsin işte bulamadım birleşim bir şey
yapıyorum hissi orada güçlü olmuştu ben
orada anlamıştım hikayenin her şey
olduğunu bu baştaki işte en sevdiğim
renk sarıdır ben kendim işte hayatıma
Daha bir hikaye vermem
reklamcılar kadar veya kitap bir hikaye
kadar çim hayatımı onun üzerine getir
geçirme leydim bu düşünüyordum şimdi de
böyle alıyorum ya şimdi düşündüm de
kendi Hayat hikâyeleri olacağını asla
kestiremiyorum kestirememek hoşuma
gidiyor Ama eskiden bak kesin şeydi bu
sınırlıydı Baba belliydi ne yapacağını
biliyordum öyle düşünüyorum şimdi seç
bilmiyorum ve Aslında bu o kadar güzel
Aslında her şey o kadar yoluna giriyor
ki mesela 30 yaşına geldim Ve bu dert
edindiğini bir şeydir çünkü hep
ajansından küçüğüm hep arkadaş grubundan
küçüldüm ve öp bir şey yapmadığım için
geleceğim için bir şey yapmadığımı
düşünüyordum ama aslında biraz daha
büyüyünce anlıyorsunuz yapalım küçük
küçük detaylı ve olduğunuz kişinin
yaptığı şeyler küçük bir çaba dahil
yazdığı bir şiir dahi gece o kadar büyük
etkisi oluyor o kadar bir kartopu etkisi
oluyor Ben işte bir bunalıma giriyorum
hiçbir şey üretmiyorum hiçbir şey Yar
atmıyorum işte ne yapacağım gelecekte
bunu hayal etmedim diye ama aslında
alttan alta o kadar çok şey
biriktiriyoruz ki bu Geleceğiniz için
veya gerçekten istediğiniz ya Ne
bakıyorsun önüne çıkmış Ve bundan Senin
sırtına itekleyen şeyler oluyor ve ben
yani hayatta böyle şey genelde kendime
saldırmayı seven biri olduğu için en çok
Kendine işlemi olunca bunu adlı
keşfetmek için çok güzeldi ve
her şeyin geçtiğini ve geçmiş zaten bir
tanem biriktirdiğimiz E bu şekilde
Anladım süreme bakacağım
olmuş
o
oluyorum da her şeyin geçtiği kısmı da
şöyle yani gerçekten yatılı okuldaki
sürecinde veya dergi zamanın sürecinde
ve hatta yani şeyde üçgen mesela köydeki
evimiz mezarlığın yanındaydı ve ben o
mezarlığın Dedem kahvehane oraya götürdü
markete oradan geri geçirirken işte
kendin gitti de ben o mezarlığın
yanından geçiyor Ödüm kopardı gece daha
imkanı bu yol Biter mi Bu Yol bitti
mesela Çok Zor Günlerim Oldu Ajans Nesa
ilk işe başladığımda reklamcısı
başaramayacağını bu herşeyi geçti ne
kadar o kadar büyük bir inancım var Kim
ve bunu herkese söylemeye çalışıyorum ve
aynı zamanda Aslında farkında olmadan
geleceğim için istediklerin için bütün
şeyler büyüklüğü sadece yapıp bırakmak
lazım işte çok yarım kalan kafamda olan
şeyler var hiç bir tatlı çok ama emin
dahi olmasam da işte gönderdiğim o
kitabın acısı ve o siviller onlar önüme
çıktı Yani büyüklük asla konuşabilecek
durumda değilim Ben de öğlen başlamasını
diyebileceğim bir şey varsa bu konuda
ta Mükemmel olmasını beklemek değil de
evet ben bunu yaptım ve ben Bundan
kurtulmak istiyorum Bu benim elimden şu
an çıktı mı başka bir şey gidebilirim
diye her şeyi atmak bu sosyal medyanın
dijitalin ve aptamilin daha eskiye
gidersek çıkmasıyla o kadar genişlik
şeyimiz ulaşım almamız ve herkese
ulaşabiliyor olmak ve bu kendine
yediremez bu mail atmayın Bir şey talep
etmemiş istemiyorum diye aynı istemenin
veya istediği Ya aslında şeyler bize
lütfettiği için olmadığını Onların da
yararlı olduğunu anlamak çok değerliydi
yaşlı gibi konuşmak istemem ama yani
Keşke Bunlar daha önceden bilseydim de
kendini paralama Saydım unuu çok
isterdim önceden Bilmem istemişti her
şey olur her şey geçer falan filan var
değil de bunların olduğunu her şey
yoluna girdim daha önceden bilseydim
aramazdım kendimi çok çıkmazdım ya
kendimi çok şey önüne engel koymazdım
diye düşünüyorum
Başka bir şey olarak yani yazık yapmadın
yani Şunu yapmak istemedim çünkü
ben de sıkılıyorum ben bazen bizde
yapıyorduk böyle etkinlikler atacaksın
tüm konuşmanın bazı akülü işte hayat
hikayelerini odaklanmayı seviyordum Ben
de kendi ayak yolum anlatayım ki işte
belki bir şey bir işe yarar sizin
kafanızda belki Hani bu arada akla gelir
diye böyle bir hazırlık yaptım rendeye
bu
ne söyle
soru-cevap alabilir misin tabi izin
şeyler diyebilirsin sonra da baktım
varsa sana izleyicilerden gelen soruları
gideceğim
örnekleri diyeceğim şey olarak
bundan sonraki sürecimi düşündüğümde
ama en büyük şeyin geleceğim sen büyük
etkili Hangi arkadaşlarım olduğunu
düşünüyorum biriktirdiğim insanlar mesaj
gerçekten değer verdiğim şekilde değer
verdim arkadaş olmaktan gurur duyduğum
insanlar biriktirmiş onu Şu an hem de en
mutlu olduğum şey Çünkü
şöyle şeyler oluyor işte görüyoruz da şu
an iki farklı noktada değerli insanın
üniversiteden arkadaşı olduğunu lise
arkadaşım ev arkadaşı olmaya çok işte da
hiç kendilerini gösteremediği zamanlarda
birlikte bir şey yapmaya çalıştıklarını
görüyoruz Mesela bu beni çok
heyecanlandırdı hikaye en sevdiğim
hikayeler böyle oluyor işte zamanında
bir yol arkadaşlık yapıyorsan O kişiyle
Aslında birlikte aynı amacın ol bu kafa
dengi olur mu onunla beraber O yola
çıkmış oluyorsun bir gün bir yerlerde
birbirinizi mutlaka çekiyorsunuz oraya
bir yerde tekrar karşılaşıyorsunuz
zevkinize daha yerlere gelmez belki bize
ekleyerek daha iyi yerlere geldiniz O
yüzden ya şu anki Hayatımda en çok
korktuğum şey doğru arkadaşlar ve
sevdiğim ve değerli insanların olması ve
onlar da beni değerli görüp işte
çevrelerinde barındırması Bu klan gibi
birşey diyebiliriz Aslında birlikte
üretilen birlikte tüketilen işte zorluk
ve zaten ileride de şu oluyor ya bu zor
günler işte ya çabaladığım dinlenmesi
Berkay Loader gibi bugün de şunu şu
anlatmak istemiştir Çünkü geçti el
ileride de bu günleri geçirip işte daha
iyi bir yerlere geldiğimizi bugünlere
anlatmak çok iyi bir okey bir his
verecek çok mutluluk verecek ve o
günlerin heyecanı ile şu an daha fazla
icim oluyor çünkü çok önemli bir anda
işte Herşeyden vazgeçebilen olmuyor
diyebilen biriken böyle göre göre yapa
yapa Bu arada oldu bitti veya işte bak
beraber ne güzel şeyler yapıyoruz diye
diye böyle motivasyon sağlıyor kendimi
bunu anlatabilirim sonra sorularınız
varsa sorularınız alabilirim
Teşekkür ederim canım